we begin in Israel where hundreds of
thousands of people have rallied against
the government's plans to change the
Judiciary they want prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu to scrap his campaign
to curtail some of the Supreme Court's
Powers the kinetic is due to vote on the
proposed government bill on Monday about
10 000 military reservers say they're
suspending voluntary service in
opposition to the policy
I'm here because the extremists are
trying to change our regime they got
into power and they are trying to make
us a weak democracy and
protest everything that is happening in
the state of Israel I think the
situation requires all of us to stand up
democracy and humanism are being eroded
on a daily basis by politicians
religious figures and leaders of
communities in the country and we need
to do something about it we need to say
enough is enough
has more now from Tel Aviv
all of the protesters that are out this
evening and Tel Aviv are opposed to the
very controversial plans of prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu to try and
overhaul the Judiciary of Israel this is
the 29th week of protests there is a
massive amount of people here already
and it's expected the numbers will only
grow and this is not the only
demonstration that's taken taken place
today there have been at least 12 other
demonstrations throughout the country
including tens of thousands of people
that were marching from Tel Aviv making
their way to the knesset in West
Jerusalem where they will demonstrate
against the debate that is scheduled to
start Sunday on the potential passage of
a very controversial bill that would see
critics say the oversight powers of the
Supreme Court weaken substantially if it
were to pass now prime minister
Netanyahu says he is committed to
continue with these plans and that once
this bill passes he will then step back
and try to seek compromise with
opposition parties but that's not good
enough for the thousands upon thousands
of people that are out across Israel who
say that this is a real threat to
democracy and that if these plans are
put in place it will take Israel away
from democracy and put it on a road to
autocracy
Tel Aviv